what we want to do today would be to
welcome our panelists for this panel
entitled pork religion and identity so
we have three very distinguished
speakers today who I will just introduce
all at once so first up would be dr.
Aaron girls who is an assistant
professor of theology and religious
studies at the University of San Diego
he is also the author of the question of
animal and religion theoretical sticks
and practical applications and he'll be
sharing his paper with us today our
second speaker is a professor Jordan
rosenblum who is the belcher professor
of classical Judaism and the University
of wisconsin-madison and he's the author
of hooded identity of Emily rabbinic
Judaism and our final speaker has plenty
of talents of mr. Jeffrey yours going
since our journalists he's an author
he's also shift and he's the publisher
of the website the book memoirs so I
will refer to do i do have you don't
look to the Past speaker today I so good
morning everyone I found last night's
panel particularly remarkable and I
decided to modify my remarks that I
could directly engage in what I was
originally gonna going to do here and in
some sense I will still do that is talk
about the new subfield of animals in
religion I'm working under the
assumption that i'm one of the few
people in religious studies in the room
in the last 15 years we've really had a
vibrant conversation start and there's
some very valuable insights coming out
of that and my original idea was to give
you a kind of overview of some of these
things and then point them towards the
pig but in many ways what I'm going to
do really is just start utilizing those
insights and demonstrate what their
value might be how they might help us
think about these questions differently
so returning to the panel this evening
when I was kind of trying to
characterize in my own head why I found
it so stimulating
the adjectives that kept coming to my
mind was symphonic it was was kind of
like a symphony what I mean by that was
each presenter you know hit a particular
note had a particular voice and at first
those voices sounded discordant as is
the case with really good music and then
by the end of the evening there was
something that was holding it together
at least for me experientially and why a
symphony why that metaphor well what do
we say when we have really beautiful
music we talk about it as moving as
powerful somehow when we bring certain
voices together the elements of them
congeal to produce something that moves
us in a way the individual elements
won't now as I said this is a simple
observation about what I experienced and
what I want to do here is explore why I
might have experienced that sense of
symphony amongst these diverse voices
maybe some of you will have emphasized
that that and to do that I want to use
utilize the work of Jacques Derrida and
draw out some of its implications to
anticipate my conclusion will be quite
simply simple namely that the conflict
between vegan and omnivore as it is
often created as profound as it is as
much attention as I think as I think it
is worth is not the most important
conflict before us and mistaking this
conflict as something that's more
central than it is assists and helps the
survival of the factory farm so to help
us think about these conflicts between
vegan and nom Anor between the factory
farm and its alternative dairy da tells
a kind of story that's all I'm going to
attempt to frame it a story about how
Western civilization has come to think
about intrigued animals differently in
the course of the last two centuries let
me begin with a substantial quote
everybody knows what the production
breeding transport and slaughter of
these animals has become instead of
thrusting these images
in your faces or awakening them in your
memory something that would be both too
easy and endless let me simply say a
word about this pathos if these images
are pathetic if they evoke sympathy it
is also because they pathetically open
the immense question of pathos and the
pathological precisely that is of
suffering pity and compassion and the
place that has to be accorded to the
interpretation of this compassion to the
sharing of this suffering among the
living to the law ethics and politics
that must be brought to bear upon this
experience of compassion what has been
happening for two centuries now involves
the new experience of this compassion so
dairy that takes this word compassion
and he uses it to name something that he
argues has always been with us but that
we are experiencing in a new way
interpreting in a new way so what is
this new experience of compassion he
writes in response to what is for the
moment the irresistible but
unacknowledged unleashing and the
organized disavowal of this torture here
he's referring to factory farming the
organized disavowal of this torture
voices are raised minority weak marginal
voices little assured of their discourse
of their right to discourse and of the
enactment of their discourse within the
law as a declaration of rights in order
to protest in order to appeal to what is
still presented in such a problematic
way as animal rights in order to awaken
us to our responsibilities and our
obligations visa be the living in
general and precisely to this
fundamental compassion so the new
experience of compassion is a response
to a new kind of disavowal of animal
lives the new kind of violence to
animals and the culminating material
correlate of that manifestation is the
factory farm so Derrida has a kind of
long this longer history
how he's thinking about the factory farm
goes back two centuries derrida then
moves us to talk about the shift and he
uses Jeremy Bentham here the founder of
utilitarian thinking as a kind of symbol
and exemplar of this new experience of
compassion what he calls a problematic
shift and he ultimately comes to
identify this with a war a term that's
going to be important now Jerry dad does
not see any clear line of progress I
want to make that clear to this quote
taken out of context could give you that
sense but rather a kind of endless
conflict between different positions
around animals that has taken a
particular shape in the last two
centuries he writes it is in thinking of
the source and ends of this compassion
that about two centuries ago someone
like Bentham as is well known proposed
changing the very form of the question
regarding the animal that domesticated
discourse within the tradition that it
dominated interesting slep that
dominated discourse within the tradition
in the language both of its most refined
philosophical argumentation and of every
day except ation it is high speech
sometimes call and the common language
we speak in both of these discourses we
had a kind of new thing happen Bentham
said something like this there are da
rights the question is not to know
whether the animal can think reason or
speak etc something we still pretend to
be asking ourselves the first and
decisive question would rather be to
know whether animals can suffer can they
suffer asked spent them simply yet so
profoundly no one can deny the suffering
fear or panic at error or fright that
can see certain animals and that we
humans can witness let us note the
following the response to the question
can they suffer leaves no room for doubt
in fact it has never left room for doubt
that is why the experience that we have
of it is not even indubitable it
proceeds the indubitable it is older
than it no doubt either then of their
being with us the possibility of getting
bent to
surge of compassion even if it is then
misunderstood repressed or denied held
at bay before the undeniable I cuss who
suffer for them and with them before
this response that precedes all other
questions both ground and cornerstone of
this shift the two centuries I have been
referring to somewhat casually in order
to situate the present in terms of this
tradition have been those of an unequal
struggle a war whose inequality could
one day be reversed being waged between
on the one hand those who violate not
only animal life but even in also this
sentiment of compassion and on the other
hand those who appeal for an irrefutable
testimony to this pity war is waged over
the matter of pity this war is probably
ageless but and here is my hypothesis it
is passing through a critical phase we
are passing through that phase and it
passes through us so before I move on to
gloucester e dot let me just refresh our
memory about some of the voices on the
panel and i'm going to uplift two voices
just because i can't touch on on all
seven and do a more thorough and
bringing them together the first one I
want to uplift is the voice that Terry
Spence brought to the table when folks
will remember that mr. Spence identified
himself as a farmer self-identified true
farmer somebody who is at fighter of the
factory farm and someone who spoke
rather eloquently I thought about the in
tolerability of the factory farm from
the perspective of the true farmer and
spoke rather powerfully about the
respect for animals that seems so
central to his own way of looking at it
and the other voice I want to lift up is
that of Bob kami who as former pig
farmer turned vegetable farmer and vegan
challenged us that even these ethical
questions that we try to raise are
insufficient to the ontological reality
of the pig I'm just going to say the
pinkness of
pig pig pneus of the pig somehow
launches us beyond ethics somehow a
response that proceeds ethics and that
response for candy it means the pig is
inviolable that means you cannot eat the
pic so these are two voices which in the
popular discourse are often kind of
pitted against one another to
sophisticated versions of voices that
are often pitted against one another and
we might wonder if the worid area da
speaks about is between these voices
between the person who cannot accept
that the pig can be violated and the
person who sees that acceptable within a
context of respect but i don't think
that's the case so dari that argues that
we're going to war a war in a critical
phase I think we all here know that the
stakes are enormous I appreciate the way
very Estabrook put it to us between farm
a and B there's this enormous Delta you
invoke that rather nicely in his
personal descriptions so moving too
quickly let us adopt Derrida's
vocabulary for a moment and return to
the panel and spectrum reviews that I've
kind of gesture dat here located between
county and spends much of the popular
discourse would have us believe that the
war the real conflict is between Campion
spends between vegetarian and omnivore
and this framing has enormous
consequences for resource distribution
and intergroup cooperation if I had more
time it would really want to draw this
out the way this is not just some kind
of ideological disagreement that we
argue over in colleges but it shapes the
way vast resources are distributed in
this country which then shape policy but
in this moment I think there's a more
compelling and more productive reading
the war which derrida speaks is not
today between the vegetarian and the
meat eater the war is between those who
quote violate not only animal life but
even and also this sentiment of
compassion and on the other hand those
who appeal to an irrefutable testimony
to this pity an irrefutable testimony to
this pity I would argue that both camis
argument that the pig pneus of the pig
leaps over ethical questions and demands
and inviolability in a religious
register ultimately
errors important ground with Spencer are
dispenses argument that a true farmer
would find factory farming intolerable
my memory is correct that word
intolerable was the precise word the
language of in tolerability is also a
kind of launch into the sphere of the
sacred the in tolerability of the
factory farm is not the same as the
inviolability of pig but nor are these
sentiments necessarily at war in the OS
compromised world in which we actually
live vegetarian or vegan and omnivore
have real disagreements real conflicts
conflicts that matter and I do not wish
at all for these conflicts to stop or
even be reduced if by conflict we mean
debate and engagement with others who
disagree I am all for that conflict the
more of that conflict the better but is
this the conflict but is this conflict
the war of which gary-da speaks the war
the war in which I think a cam he an
dispense are on the same side is not if
we are following dare you don simply an
ethical dispute but something deeper we
might call it an ontological war a war
of religion that is I think cami is
right to say that the pig leaps over
ethics to the realm of the sacred to the
ground from which epics Springs ground
is one of the terms important for dairy
da here for candy and many others what
happens at this ground this foundation
demands the inviolability of the pig for
Spence and many more others the pig can
be killed with must be respected these
are different responses but I submit
both are occurring in this register of
depth both are authentic responses to
something that cannot altima tlie be
wholly accounted for in the language of
ethics and this something this very
ground of the ethical is what the
factory farm has violated what is the
authentic response to this ground where
we encounter the pig pneus of pigs the
diverse views of the panel clearly
expressed some important disagreements
on the question of killing now I can
think a few more productive questions to
raise in our classrooms in our homes and
our professional lives then whether at
this moment we should be eating me
but we cannot forget as we do this that
this important and Aegis conflict
between vegan and omnivore today takes
place in the context of a larger war and
we cannot let ourselves our nation's
forget this the stakes are too high the
suffering too vast the moment to urgent
our context today demand seeing at least
a political alliance but and this is the
entire force of my remarks I believe we
have more than an expedient political
alliance between the vegans and the
omnivore that is what made the diverse
conflicted voices of the panel resonate
in my mind as symphonic rather than
discordant and at least this is my bad
attentiveness to the shared religious or
sacred call or dimension to defend not
only animal lives but compassion could
go a long way towards ultimately ending
the factory farm thank you we're going
to do three in a row and then questions
okay thank you now going to try and
cover three thousand years of history in
20 minutes in august two thousand six a
Virginia senator named George Allen was
in the midst a controversial bid for
reelection his campaign which would
prove unsuccessful was on its heels
after several missteps including his
reported ownership of stock in a company
that sold the morning after pill a
problematic investment for a candidate
running on the Republican ticket himself
and his use of a racial slur later that
same month another potential scandal
came to light namely the fact that his
mother might have Jewish lineage
according to the matrilineal principle
of Jewish law Jewish identity is
imparted by one's biological mother if
your biological mother is Jewish than
you are Jewish though a member of the
presbyterian church allen now had to
explain this revelation about his will
and ethnic identity to his constituency
almost a month later the New York Times
reported the following exchange quote I
still had a ham sandwich for lunch mr.
Allen told the Richmond times-dispatch
referring to rules against eating pork
and my mother made great port my mother
made great pork chops and chrome in
denying the relevance of his distant
Jewish past one that he had only learned
about a couple of days earlier before
uttering these words Alan turned to the
food on his plate and one food in
particular the pig it is telling that he
also highlighted his mother's culinary
prowess with regard to pork chops since
it was her lineage that he wished to
complicate he clearly used pig to
problematize and marginalize her Jewish
identity after all how Jewish could his
mother be she made great pork chops
though Alan was probably not aware of it
he was engaging in a millennia-old
practice of utilizing pig to locate self
and other on an identity map as either
inside or outside the territory marks as
Jewish in this common historical trope
the pig functions as a semiotic sign
invested much signification I therefore
use Alan's scandal and to introduce this
process which I will playfully referred
to as the swine and the signified so
this trope has its origins in the
Biblical Book of Leviticus Leviticus 11
attributed to the priestly or P source
addresses the dietary laws concerning
five categories of animals within the
first four categories subsets of animals
are either permitted or tabooed the
fifth category which is small land
animals which we learned about their
domestication earlier is completely
prohibited in discussing the first
category of animals or quadrupeds a
criterion for ingestion is provided only
those quadrupeds that have split hooves
and chew the cud can be eaten Leviticus
11 4 through 7 then enumerates for
animals that it deems to have one but
not both of the criteria the camel the
rock badger and the hare chew the cud
but do not have split hoods and the pig
has split hooks but does not chew the
cud Leviticus neither offers a
justification for this taboo nor singles
out the pig from the seemingly humble
origin the culinary regulation
concerning the pig in a Leviticus 11 7
will take on a life
zone and eventually be viewed as perhaps
the most well-known biblical taboo it is
in the Second Temple period from roughly
5 15 BCE to 70 see that the pig begins
to emerge as a particularly important
meet visa V Jewish identity both Jewish
and non-jewish sources from this era
devote more time to discussing the pig
than to any other biblically forbidden
quadrupeds the reason why the big the
pig is placed front and center in these
texts remains unclear was the pig aboard
more than any other non pusher beast at
the time or was pig simply the most
commonly encountered non-kosher kraj
ahead for inhabitants of Roman Palestine
we simply do not know regardless the
absence of the pig from the Jewish men
you proved worthy of note for both
Jewish and non-jewish authors in the
ancient world in discussing Judaism
ancient Greek and Roman authors ponder
why Jews engage in three practices
Sabbath observance circumcision and
abstention from pork what Jews did and
did not eat therefore serves as a
mechanism for exploring Jewish
difference in their examinations of this
dietary difference ancient non-jewish
authors off often simply make casual
reference to or provide ethnographic
explanations for this peculiar peculiar
culinary behavior for the Latin satirist
seeeeee the Jewish pork temper was a
vehicle for humor as the lake christian
about nelia aptly observes quote an
ancient and consistent series of porcine
toh koi was used by Greek and Roman
authors to answer the difficult question
what is the identity of the Jews by
answering the apparently more specific
and thus seemingly easier question why
do jews avoid eating pork unquote in
this sense pork truly is the other white
meat and i should quickly add as an
aside almost a decade ago here my first
paper on pork at Yale at a grad
conference so and it was called the
other white meat laughs the most
fascinating port-related interactions
between Jews and non-jews are found in
ancient Jewish sources for example 2nd
and 4th Maccabees each contain two
complex accounts of pork related Jewish
martyrdom at the hands of Antiochus the
villain of the Hanukkah story the first
concerning an old man named Eleazar and
the second details that have a mother
and her
Suns all nine of these characters are
offered the opportunity to eat pork
rather than die and all choose martyrdom
over meat while these accounts are
literary that does not mean that we
cannot glean historical information from
them what we learn from these narratives
is that pig represented other pneus to
eat pork was an active identification
concomitant Lee to announce pork was to
engage in a practice of identification
as well one's relationship with pork
therefore was and remains unto today
fraught with symbolic association it was
during this time period when that
particular connection began the Second
Temple period comes to an end in 70 CE
II when the second temple was destroyed
at the hands of room is worth noting
that the Roman legion that accomplished
this task was the leggio 10 for Texas
whose symbol was the board at the time
Judaism was a temple based religion so
the disappearance of this central cultic
site was nothing short of a theological
economic and social catastrophe the
rabbi is the ancient group of the group
of ancient Jews to whom I devote the
majority of my scholarly inquiry sought
to fill the vacuum created in the wake
of this loss as I've written elsewhere
the rabbi's associated Rome with the pig
like the pig Rome appeared kosher on the
outside which belied it's a turn its
internal corruption further rebenok
remembrances of the Second Temple of the
destruction of the Second Temple often
describe the use of pig as a weapon
deployed by Rome or V pig in order to
physically and symbolically conquer
Jerusalem the rabbi's thus inherited and
expanded the tradition of swine and
signified wherein the pig as a somatic
sign invested with signification of
other pneus one fascinating tale which I
couldn't resist talking about in this
connection faces central is a potential
menage tois between two very beautiful
Roman women and the renowned rabbi Akiba
visiting rome the great rabbi akiva is
slandered I eat is falsely reported that
he enjoys in the company of one
commentator the company of loose women
healing this Roman general sends two
beautiful and all gussied up ladies to
rabbi Akiba zoo bedroom where they
anticipate an evening of pleasure and
fornication alas Rob Akiva proves
unwilling to engage in what appears to
be both an inch
and modern male fantasy sabe Akitas
refusal is part of a rabbinic trope of
self-restraint a societal ideal
influenced by contemporaneous Greek and
Roman followed philosophy extolling
self-control and self master what is
interesting for the discussion of hand
is a pun contained in the beautiful
woman's solicitation of Rabbi Akiva each
says to him turn towards me in Hebrew
hazard sleep the Hebrew for the word
turn bizarre is morphologically similar
to the word for pig or kezia only one
vowel sound distinguishes them the
woman's words reinforce the scent that
Rabbi Akiva attributes to them that a
pig meat this association between Roman
women and pig is not random rather it's
part of a long tradition in which Pig
services a metonym for Rome Romans and
Roman asst thus when Robbie icky Ricky
vu remarks the basis that these
non-jewish woman's smell of various non
kosher foods it is quite important that
pig appears on this list it has become
the non-kosher beast par excellence due
to its association with roman identity
the very words that these very beautiful
women used to try and seduce him are
reminders of their non-jewish or traith
non-kosher identity one can actually use
an American English vulgarism for coitus
to render this term exactly how it
sounded to Rabbi Kiva's ears instead of
saying turn towards me rabbi heard kiva
heard each woman employing him pork
minute over the ensuing centuries Jews
continue to view pork consumption as a
practice of non-jewish identity
formation for example while Jews are
allowed to hire non-jews as wet nurses
for their children and while young
Jewish children are permitted to eat
non-kosher food 1 13th century rabbi
cautions quote one should warn the
non-jewish wet-nurse not to eat impure
foods or pork and certainly not to feed
the infants in pure substances for
everything that a woman eats the
infinites and quote while pork is
clearly an impure food it is single out
here to symbolize both the diet the diet
of the non jew and the potential threat
it and by extension the non-jew herself
presents to a Jewish infant suckling
from her bosom but Jews were not the
only ones probably getting this
association non-jews increasingly turned
to the pig
demark a Jewish identity no less a
literary master than William Shakespeare
plays with this motif when in the
Merchant of Venice Bassanio invites the
complicated Jewish character [ __ ] to
dinner in response to this invitation
[ __ ] replies quote yes to smell pork
to eat of the habitation which our
prophet the Nazarite conjured the
devlins you I will buy with you sell
with you talk with you walk with you and
so following but I will not eat with you
drink with you nor pray with you and
probe as David Goldstein asks quote why
is the first thing that we learn about
[ __ ] besides the fact that he
practices usually that he doesn't eat
pigs because his goldstein concludes
pork functions both in the play and in
the so called Judeo Christian religious
imaginary as a metonym for the
difference between Christian and Jewish
criminality pork in the merchant acts
almost as an ayah as iodine doesn't a
cat-scan throwing the ink
interconnections and blockages of the
plays body into relief and gloat it is
telling that the pig is the symbol of
this dividing line as it represents both
the fault line down the table and the
identity of those who partake and
abstain from its flesh sometimes the
association between Jewish identity and
pork plays out in seemingly
contradictory ways a fascinating example
of this appears in the wake of the event
that according to the renowned
historians Monty Python nobody expects
the Spanish Inquisition faced with
expulsion death or conversion some Jews
fled some were martyred and some
converted amongst the latter group the
conversos many converted in name only
and then practice the continued to
practice Judaism in secret this was
referenced yesterday such people are
often referred to as crypto-jews and
were the subject of much consternation
since they were seen to mock the system
one pejorative term for crypto-jews was
Marranos etymologically murano comes
from the arabic muharram meaning the
thing that is forbidden as claudine
fabri visage notes quote this
demonstration shows the affiliation an
ethnologist should not be surprised that
the forbidden animal should be named by
the word signifying the interdiction
itself unquote once again the swine
functions as a sign despite its Arabic
boots and the obvious connection with
Islam after all the pain
is the only category typhoon animal in
the Quran the term Murano refers to
Jewish converts to Catholicism who
continue to practice Judaism in secret
they are pigs just as ancient rabbis
accused Rome of masquerading like the
pig whose external kosher appearance
cloaks its internal non-kosher
corruption fear Iberian Catholics
accused crypto-jews of hiding behind a
force on masks while they may play the
role of the non-jew the pig in public
they remain corrupt hence they are
called pigs Christians in particular
seized on this pig is symbol of
non-jewish pneus and therefore
associated one who abstained from pork
with non-christian behavior often
referred to as Judaizing this
understanding informs in 18th century
song from burgundy which claims that
quote while the Jewish law prohibits
Lord is heretical the same is not so in
Christian lands let us eat fresh pork
let us eat the more we enjoy the piglet
the better Catholics we become and quote
the more one eats pork the more one
demonstrates their Christian piety
leaving pork off one's plate after all
is a very Jewish thing to do even
progressive Jews who eschewed
traditional kosher laws found the
practice of pork consumption problematic
a notable example of this phenomenon
occurred on July eleventh 1883 when the
Hebrew Union College in Cincinnati Ohio
hosted a banquet to celebrate the
ordination of the college's first class
reform rabbis the menu for this gourmet
feast later infamously known as the tray
for non kosher banquet included four
bibley forbidden foods clams crabs
shrimp and frogs for those counting at
home and violated other Vinick dietary
regulations by serving non kosher meat
and mixing milton over a series of
elaborate courses the dinosaur partook
of this feast and those who stormed out
each made a statement about performed
judaism stance on the traditional Jewish
dietary laws and by extension on its
theology in general the intra and inter
denominational consternation inspired in
part by the trailer banquet contributed
to the bifurcation of American Judaism
still evidence today lost in the haze of
those who didn't did not eat the clams
crab shrimp and frogs was the fact that
this transgressive meal did not violate
one particular biblical
type of pork never appeared on the menu
since his back banquet was served in
Cincinnati a city nicknamed pork opolis
this absence is worthy of note though
two years later the reform movement
would adopt the Pittsburgh platform that
rejected quote all such mosaic Roma
binnacle laws that regulate diet end
quote Reform Judaism initially did not
violate this particular dietary
prohibition in fact initial discussion
about reform judaism stance on non
kosher food in America sent around two
foods pork and oysters with the result
in general opinion that pork was
prohibited oysters were permitted as a
sea creature with neither fins no scales
oysters are not kosher they were however
tasty affordable popular considered
healthy as and as an added bonus and
aphrodisiac these factors led rabbi
Isaac may arise founder of the Hebrew
Union College to refer to or 20 stirs as
ocean vegetables to argue that quote
there can be no doubt that the oyster
shell is the same to all intents and
purposes as the scales and fins on clean
fish protecting against certain gases in
the water and thus end quote and thus to
permit their ingestion no such
interpretation accord occurred for pork
it was within this what one scholars
called no pork yes Easter viewpoint that
we discern the legacy of more than 2
million two millennia of historical
baggage and even when this baggage seems
safely stowed away is emerges from
storage to reassert itself such as the
role that pork plays in the popularity
of chinese food amongst american jews in
a famous essay originally published in
1992 sociologist Tuchman and levine
suggest several reasons in the words of
Jennifer Utley why chal mein is the
chosen food of the chosen people one of
the primary reasons for this association
is the fact that the pork shellfish and
other biblically prohibited foodstuffs
or staples of Chinese cooking these
tablet ingredients are disguised via
common Chinese cooking techniques in
which the common animal are the
forbidden animal proteins are cut
chopped and minced a Jewish patron might
be willing to eat a pile of
unrecognizable chopped white meat in a
sea of salty noodles but might not need
a pork chop the latter is unambiguously
trade for non kosher while the former is
a meat of unknown origin tantamount to a
culinary don't ask don't tell policy
tockman and levine labeled this
principle of misrecognition safe trip it
allowed American Jews to transgress
without feeling transgressive two months
left but I might have to go a minute
over apologize the connection between
pork and Jewish identity is so common
that it appears even when an alternative
interpretation of the porcine data seems
more likely for example in 1994 Quentin
Tarantino film pulp fiction the
following exchange occurred between two
fellow contract killers Vincent want
some bacon Jules no man I don't eat pork
Vincent are you Jewish Jules now I had
Jewish I just don't dig on the swine
that's all Vincent why not Jules pigs
are filthy animals I don't eat filthy
animals Vincent bacon takes good pork
chops tastes good anko I'm not an actor
so apologize yeah when Vincent played by
the caucasian actor John Travolta
discovers the jewels played by the
african american actor samuel l jackson
refrains from ingesting pork he
immediately inquires whether Jules is
Jewish as an african-american Jules is
more likely to be a Muslim than a Jew
since both Muslims and Jews do not eat
pork we need to ask why Vincent suspects
that Jules dietary practice drives his
adherence to Judaism and not Islam
perhaps Jules penchant for quoting
ezekiel 25 17 a pseudo biblical passage
prior to executing someone influence
Vincent's question however I would argue
that is not only because it adds a small
layer of humor door imagine the african
american assassin Jules as a Jew but
because of the historical association
between pork and Jewish identity muslims
may not eat pork butt is historically
more common to presume that a patron who
profanes pork is a Jew a coda to this
paper that is going to make me a minute
over recently presented itself when
another Republican politician from the
south used pork to discuss Jewish
identity in an interview in February
first 2015 with CNN former Arkansas
governor Mike Huckabee remarked in
regard to his views on gay marriage
quote it's like asking somebody who's
Jewish to start serving bacon-wrapped
shrimp on it in their deli we don't do
that I mean we're not going to do that
or asking a Muslim to you know to serve
up something that is offensive to him or
to have dogs in his backyard
and for once again the Muslim pork taboo
is either minimized or ignored but
Huckabee's example of bacon wrapped
shrimp as representing Christian
attitudes towards gays sexuality
marriage indicates that the pork taboo
is a central component Jewish identity
forcing Jews to serve such a product in
their delis a quintessential American
Jewish dining establishment is tansy
knape and Huckabee's opinion to forcing
Christian business business owners to
accept marriage equality serving and can
commonly eating pork functions as a
synecdoche for forced violation of
jewish practices gay marriage proponents
are therefore cast in the role of
Antiochus the villa gate the villain of
the Hanukkah story mentioned earlier who
forced you to eat pork in this metaphor
Huckabee's Christians are the Jewish
martyrs who chose death rather than
consuming pork once again pork indexes
Jewish identity only now it would seem
Christian who engages in Judaizing
behavior who excused pork is a good
Christian pork continues to play an
important role in talking about Jews
Judaism Jewish identity and the rhetoric
beliefs and practices of others in
relation to Jews duties of a Jewish
identity if history has taught us
anything it is that we should expect the
presence or absence of pork from one's
diet to be laden with meaning for years
to come thank
hello I'm Jeffrey oz quits I am a writer
I am a owner of a gefilte fish business
what am I doing here talking about pork
it's the big question i I've spent many
years writing about the pork industry
yeah in Israel and also reading about
the Jewish relationship and the
connection to k's and that brought me to
israel a number of years ago when i
started my research actually moved on to
an Israeli pink farm spent time
researching the topic speaking with the
Israelis and I came to see that the pork
taboo that Jordan was speaking about
usually I have to spend a lot of time
talking about the taboo and all of the
the associations and the history in the
challenges but I'm so glad you went
first so I don't have to focus on that
but the the tableau place itself out in
a really interesting way and you start
to see that as the founding of a state
of israel you actually have a almost
consensus so general feeling that this
pork taboo is relevant and culturally a
part of the israeli uh cultural life and
today you start to see that that taboo
has eroded and actually uh the biggest
started to symbolize something new with
in Israeli society a new secular
identity a new marker of identity so
that's what I want to talk about today
and while looking at the Israeli pork
industry a little overview I moved to
Tel Aviv in 2007 to begin my research
fellowship program University and about
two days after I arrived there was an
arson attack against the shop selling
pork matinee Aviv this is a spot one of
the holy cities suspected arsonist was a
altra Orthodox Israeli I was pretty
shocked that there was a pork shoppe
being burned apparently this happens
quite often while I was living in Tel
Aviv for three years after one year
excuse me there were three pork shops
that were attacked there was a film in
2005 called the Schwartz dynasty which
actually shows the firebombing Russian
establishment selling pork in Israel so
this is a quite common and I always
think it's interesting to think about
what it would look like or what would
smell like the smell of pig flesh
cooking you know because this fire but
this is uh just to go to show you how
how tense this issue is in this country
I'm in the founding of the Jewish state
the founding of Israel 1948 it came with
a conversation about what would the
character of this state be what would
the Jewish identity looked like and
there were debate so early scientists
suiting before the founding of the state
of israel were really uh you know trying
to make the case that you know no we're
building a new jewish identity you know
we need a distance ourselves from the
past of the diaspora the humiliation of
those associations related tote org but
yet the general consensus was that it
was it was too important to to ignore
this symbol of our modern it's the
symbol this this symbol that has kept us
from European civilization from
assimilation for all these years this is
a quote from the ton altima cyanus the
poet during these debates in the Knesset
debating whether or not that pork should
be even allowed and in Israel this is a
in the 1950s so after the founding of
the state he writes memories of
revulsion etched in by sword and whip
are now engraved as an unconscious
instinct even those unable to discern a
cloven hoofed one from one that is not
will sense this when a Jewish nation in
Israel makes the pig as sinequan on its
history shudders may this making the
case that we really can't have pork in
this country but you're also trying to
build a Democratic Society and trying to
be an open civilization what ended up
happening was overwhelming consensus in
the Israeli Knesset was to tube and pigs
in 1956 the first first law was passed
that allowed municipalities in Israel to
ban the breeding and sell of payout
pains and Tel Aviv the secular Israelis
city was one of the first to ban Japan
these days I'm and in 1962 a second law
was passed that actually
legal nationwide to raise pigs and also
mean illegal to sell pigs except in
regions that were Christian Arab in
Israel there are nine specific regions
that were that were specifically
demarcated at evil in Nazareth and malia
were among three of those so it's really
interesting a lot of Israeli pig farmers
at that time and there were some I'm
going to talk about them in a moment but
they all moved their pigs on to the Arab
lands and started partnering with with
Arabs in in production in Israel but so
what ended up happening was it became
illegal but there were exemptions and
pigs continued to be raised pigs were
always raised in Israel you know the
British period the auto in period you
always had various populations that were
breeding these animals and suddenly they
it was banned and the laws is an
incredible of these debates and the laws
are actually chronicled quite well in
the book outlawed pigs by a legal
historian and now Supreme Court justice
stuff my Barack errors i highly
recommend the book so but this is really
a fight for the soul of the country what
you'll see is that these the secular
Israelis and the religious Zionist this
relationship and support of banning pigs
is something that will erode over time
over time so in the early years of the
State of Israel in 1950s this period
known as that say 'no the years of
austerity this was a period of intense
food rations so much hunger and a lot of
these keywords knew him these are a
hallowed seeing people settling the land
this is a mrs. O'Keefe woods in the
north of Israel and they were just
trying to figure out how to survive
there were all these jokes on the on
visa the key woods is a socialist you
know agricultural collective that was
part of the founding culture of the
state of israel and there were all these
jokes of making fun of the hunger that
when would you eat a chicken a key boots
liquid only in a chicken when either he
was about to die that chicken was about
to die and how does it keep us in the
eat margarine you slice it in 16 not the
funniest jokes but you know
but jokes on the legs but um but I liked
it I spent time on a lot of different
keep would seem i lived on quibids lahav
a pig farmer in the south which I'll
talk about in a moment I'm going to met
with a lot of different octopus elders
and I found that a lot of these secular
she would seem had what I'd like to call
their pork origin stories which how they
first got their pigs in the 1950s
quibids misra I wanted my kind of most
that if you talk to any Israeli about
pork in Israel they'll say okay puts
mizerock this is the institution key
boots misra their story goes that one
key looks like one day showed up and he
had a he had a pregnant sow and he
brought her and put her into the the cow
reflect a little cow pasture area and
put in the corner that named the pig the
named her low Klum which means nothing
and so whenever the inspectors would
come to inspect the dairy operation in
Israel estate there was kosher they
would ask what's over there it's a low
blow it's nothing but then she gave
birth and they were just feeding food
scraps they're just feeding their rinds
and the peels and they fattened her up
and they had these ten piglets that were
fattening them up and suddenly these
people who were only eating meat around
Passover and Yom Kippur were suddenly
eating meat frequently and they were you
having protein and I was helping them
build their key boots and this vision of
a country and it ends up becoming an
important part of that key boots and
there are multiple stories Sony
different keywords team one story was
another keywords nearby product a pig on
Yom Kippur so the religious keep woods
nearby wouldn't see them and the story
goes the pig got out of the truck and
ended up going into the synagogue during
cold need rain and might be apocryphal
who knows it's a great story but but the
I idealist this would seem um they were
take these pigs but by providing him
sustenance and ended up becoming a
really important part of their survival
so this symbol of humiliation and
oppression ended up becoming a savior of
sorts and so that's a really important
to keep in mind um this is key boots me
so these are archival photo
of their early Pig operations key boots
musa was one of the few key would seem
that really built a plant a processing
plant and in 1962 when it was illegal to
raise pigs they were obviously not in a
christian arab region of israel they
moved their pigs but they kept the plant
and the plant is now the largest
non-kosher a processing plant in israel
of not kosher meat um and this this
plant was very inspiring for a lot of
secular keyboard sneaking well I went to
fly to Israel to begin this research
actually the security guard if you ever
fly to Israel they grill you and
interrogate you and I went there and
East asked me what i was doing i said i
was going to research the pork industry
and the first question he said to me oh
you mean like hip boots Musa I said yeah
he's just like I love their meat I
walked right through you know so it was
important and this is a chibi sphere RL
one of the key boots misra elders and a
resident historian I met with him and
spoke with him a lot about the history
of the keywords and he would just talk
with he couldn't tell you how much it
meant that they were using the best
quality meat in Israel it was so
important I'm the kibbutz ended up
selling its stake in the processing
plant in the mid-2000s because of other
financial issues but at one point
keyboards Muse were forty percent of its
revenue was coming from cakes so they
built theirs and they were one of the
successful people assume you know so
they built their success on the back of
hogs and he recognized that um at the
same time chibi was very um he wasn't
very hopeful he this is a photo from
1989's was a protest that he was part of
leading various different king drummers
and the secular keyboard sneaking they
were fighting uh what was a call to poke
lazier proposed law that would
completely ban all pimped farming in
Israel and the sale of pigs over the
years from nineteen sixty-two up until
nineteen eighty nine as there was a rift
between secular Israel and religious
Israel there was an attempt by a really
empowered religious minority in
government that has a lot of outsized
influence 22
essentially get rid of these these pigs
this is not just an eyesore but this
symbol of is anti Jewishness is unju
ishmeet and this was a protest and you
can see there's likening uh this is fear
among them so many secular Israelis I
had met a neighbor of a man named Mark
Eisenberg a neighbor of cupids misra who
said that the mise waad closes he's
leaving Israel it's a litmus test for
democracy it you know the minute it
closes Israel's become a theocracy and
so this fight is one that really
emboldened Israeli pig farmers in Israel
and cyclist really sue themselves loved
poor embolden them and made them really
appreciate that this was something they
were they were fighting these religious
forces in government and expressing
themselves as secular Jews in Israel and
its I should note that I there's still
as the taboo is still very much alive
and I most Israelis don't refer to pork
in Hebrew by its name hazir but instead
they use a series of euphemisms steak
Levon white steak pasar Levon white meat
my favorite is piranha muha which is a
short cow and but this is no joke this
is how it is referred to it you know
what Jordan writes about the idea of
devar affair Tom would it grab eyes they
wouldn't actually call pings by by by
the name in the Talmud that actually
refer to them as the other thing so I
you know in some ways this is a long
line a tradition but even those who eat
pork won't call it hazir to me that was
just shows that even as much as you can
reject this idea of abstaining from
forth you can still sort of internalize
it this is a futsal aha where I actually
lived for two months so i worked in pig
insemination now i was promoted at it
ping insemination once i was i was on
dead pig clean up and I'm subjecting
antibiotics this is an industrial pig
farm it was a miserable place everything
that was being talked about yesterday I
was feeling really intensely I should be
noted that the two men in the picture on
the left is Marcos a Jew Jewish
Argentine who does not important and on
the right is Ahmad
tinian Muslim who does not eat pork the
people who run the pig farm on keywords
lab do not import and yet this is a
kibbutz in the south of the country in
1962 when the log passed to Japan pig
reading and this is a region not in one
of the Christian Arab parts of the
country but the lawyers of kibbutz lahav
quickly suggested that they open up a
scientific research institute and get an
exemption for raising pigs for science
so this he would essentially raises pigs
for science and slaughters the excess
and it was kind of a National League
wing and although in the 90s because of
the biotech boom this actually became
quite an important pigs so to being used
for all sorts of important experiments
in Israel but up until the 90s it was
really just a front and blood q'bert's
lahav opened up a shop on its premises
on the along the highway for people to
buy pork and Israelis would come from
all over the country to drive down to
the negative 2 2 by 2 by port it became
an important right I'd met number of
Israelis for him that was that was there
Saturday ritual on Shabbat with entry to
drive down to buy pork from kibbutz loud
um this is a me just posing in front of
the pig carcasses and in the 1990s 1
million Russian immigrants from the
forms from the former Soviet Union came
in flooded into Israel about one-sixth
of Israel's population many of them
exercise the law of return they have
Jewish roots jewish one jewish
grandparent was all that was necessary
they brought with them a taste for for
pork many of them had very little
religious connection to judaism and this
is a picture of teeth tom which is a was
a up until recently the lagoon the
fastest growing a supermarket in israel
and now is just establish mint
supermarket in israel that started as a
pork shop selling pork in the caramel
market in tel aviv so this this industry
is because it was illegal to sell pork
for so long it became a black market
industry until the 1990s when a law was
passed essentially overriding
the law preventing you from selling work
so it became legal to sell pork and this
small pork shoppe that essentially
catered to Russian tastes ended up
becoming a gourmet specialty food market
in Israel that is associated now with
secular Israel it's open on the Sabbath
it was the first supermarket to reject
Sabbath observance and I had met a
number of Israelis who only shop there
to support them a managed should be
noted that in 2007 when Russian
billionaire and oligarchs ad guide amok
was running for mayor of Jerusalem he
wanted to win religious support so he
tried to buy t-tom which had become the
symbol of secular Israel to make it
culture he wanted to remove pigs he
actually didn't understand that it was
more than just removing the pigs at the
pork to make the kosher and he also
didn't realize that the only customers
were there because they sell pork and
are not kosher what I that ended up
following through but that was an
attempt for him to win religious support
because this has become such a divisive
issue and as this secular identity has
grown and expressed itself you also have
the rejection of it you saw the arson
attacks early on you have a polarization
happening and the pork industry is a
great representation of that this is le
Landau he is a food writer in Israel I
had read an article about him when he
wrote a the first Hebrew language pork
cookbook in 2010 81 recipes all of pork
Middle Eastern residents and he felt
like Israel he wrote this book and he
said that Israel was finally ready he
had hoped to embrace the pig we finally
moved beyond the beyond this taboo
that's held us back and he said if only
people knew how to cook pork well
because this really don't know how to
cook it or butcher it he said then maybe
we can see the embrace of it and he put
out this book he actually couldn't find
a publisher for the book so he
self-published it and he sold very few
copies and and it was a for him really
distressing he actually died just a few
months after I had met with him there
was about nine months after the book and
he was heartbroken that he was
unsuccessful in the Israel wasn't quite
there yet with him for him as an israeli
food writer he was one of the foremost
food writers in israel this was an
expression of
is his culinary identity as a writer was
like he learned about food in Italy he
traveled he said finally we can open up
to the world and and the country wasn't
quite there with him although he was
admired by many many in the m and the
culinary field I mean last year's want
to end with the chef manyara donia he's
a very well-known chef in Israel I hear
a restaurant petite I had to work with
him back in 2011 and he told me that
while he was alive while his mother was
alive he would never he never put pork
on the menu in the you know deference to
her she was from North African in origin
it would just be so awful for her to go
to a restaurant that he runs and seed
pork on the menu and about two years
after that he opened a new restaurant
mizlala and on his menu written not in
euphemism not not in love on what was
written was bitching has your pork belly
so within two years his mother did not
die but he he it was hard to be in the
fine dining space in Tel Aviv have a
kind of a fancy restaurant and not have
work on the menu it's become an
expectation and so what you see is a
this you know because of the laws the
anti King breeding laws the laws that
ban the selling of pork up until their
early 90s you see the the black market
nature of it made it something this way
of lowering so a lot of the people in
the food world a lot of writers and
chefs all talk about the first time they
tasted the transgressive taste of of
steak live on the first food trend in
Israel in the 70s was steak in Akita and
you'd go and you'd ask for the whites
day and so they all have that memory of
discovering the joy and the pleasure of
food which in a socialist country like
Israel was actually the pleasure of food
itself was actually uh was transgressive
as well taking pleasure in it and what's
interesting for me is that the taste you
know the taboo it's still it's still
there it's still something at once
wrestling with in Israel but the
symbolism of the pig has changed for
secular Israelis and it's become a
symbol of
almost liberation and freedom both from
from religion and from the past and also
this Orthodox tradition within the
culture and thank you so much thank you
to all the three speakers who and 44
very fascinating papers oh yes I like to
invite questions in comments sorry okay
this is really really interesting and
cross across all three papers such
continuity and so I guess this question
is for all three of you but it starts
with noting the point that Jordan was
bringing up about in particular
crypto-jews I'm not going to say that
the word correctly so I'm not going to
try to UM but the the naming of Jews as
pigs which I find really fascinating
this notion that on the one hand the pig
names the thing that they cannot eat and
yet for Gentiles the pigs are themselves
Jews and I was reminded of Richard
Walter dairy who is the Nazi Minister of
Agriculture who writes a book called the
pig as a criterion for Nordic people and
Semites sometime I think in the
mid-1930s possibility too late 1930s and
it begins with the the line pigs are
excuse me Jews are the pork of humans
and poor care specifically not not
they're not the pigs of humans but they
are they are the pork they are they a
shrine pleasure but i would i'm trying
to remember the the exact timing fork
but um what are we to make of that that
that constant sort of recurring trope
that that like the process of
identification here is both in naming
the thing that the Jews will not eat and
yet in not eating it baby comment um
that might be one one of the ways
they're talking about certainly is that
was
is sort of perspective um so actually my
wave answer my god Lee my first thought
and answering that is to think of
zombies because the in the idea being is
no because zombies are a way that's
becoming popular culture is a way of
thinking through humanists and what it
means to be human um and what it means
to not be human right and I think pig is
um because there are all these this this
complicated interesting back and forth
with humans and pigs and the humanists
or pig nests of pigs and things I think
pigs are often used to think about
humanists as well and reflect on that
and I think with the murano then with
your seeing as on different groups have
used pig to identify what groups one
belongs to how far one is outside of it
and what I was getting up with that
murano thing as you start to then see an
interesting complication where take is
sometimes it's not just used to discuss
on our is one Jewish or non-jewish but
even how how in some ways the it gets
flipped on its head but on one end is
getting flipped on its head but in that
flipping of it you're seeing how pig
really is becoming indexing of other and
it's zooming out and so calling a Jew a
pig on the one hand it makes no sense
the other hand makes actually tremendous
sense if you think of the symbolic
nature so that's what so I think that
without showing and then you could
continue on to the example you're giving
it's it's thinking about how big can be
used and that relationship with to talk
about um where one understands the
nature of a person in this particular
jus and how human or inhuman they are a
few things come to mind you had
mentioned Claudine fabric assassin who
works in the singular beast which talks
about the blood libel and the origins of
the blood libel in that this idea that
Jews themselves were not they were they
weren't eating pigs which meant that
they had any pigs themselves you know
and the idea that they would you know
that's why there would be wanting to eat
the the blood of these Gentile children
and putting them in matzah I mean not
the best doesn't make the most sense but
that's this idea the other thing that
came to my mind is also the self again
pretation that some of the Talmudic
rabbis had with that's Tom Monica by
sorry um the Kabbalistic rabbis had with
the pigs and pigs as in the show con
erika actually says that if a opinion is
there's a pestilence among pigs then
it's a duty for a rabbi to call for a
public fast and is this idea that these
rabbis had a sense that the you know
there was a similar anatomy they were
similar enough there's a similar
relationship that that you know humans
could get sick from pigs is the only
animal that the rabbis call for calling
a public fast for that's what you would
do for a morning ritual and so to me
there's almost it's almost an
acknowledgement maybe we are like these
pigs I always always appreciate that
from the rabbi's my comment question is
directed to Jeffrey um first of all the
story you told must be incredibly
disappointing to some evangelical
Christians in the United States because
some of them have actually from what I
understand taken on the pink prohibition
as part of their own identity and
they're looking and so a Christian
Zionist tradition that there be
interpreting so it's a very fascinating
story my question is about whether the
divide is simply one between religious
and secular in Israel or are you perhaps
the time didn't allow it glossing over
divided maybe between the Ashkenazi
Zanda he's in particular I'm thinking of
the question of assimilation to a quote
secular or Western culture that that
might arise much more importantly or
prominently in Ashkenazi tradition vs
I'm sorry tradition where that the issue
of pagan you know consumption would not
have come up and in that sense I'm also
curious whether there's what we see is
also wanting to assimilate into a
Western narrative but also to reject the
Middle Eastern culture that surrounds
Israeli one that is now Islamic and very
much rejecting the pig and wanting to
almost pull away and this
associate by adopting this more modern
secular discourse of pink consumption
thank you thank you it's an interesting
question now so I definitely didn't have
to not talk as much about also the
issues with Russian Israelis coming in I
wouldn't say it's a Sephardic Ashkenazi
difference i do think it is very much
secular in religious but there is among
Sephardic normies Rockley Jews Jews of
Eastern origin middle-eastern origin I
have some relatives of middle-eastern
origin there is a more traditional ISM
generally speaking and we're speaking in
general terms that were that you know I
remember when I was working on the pig
farm I went to visit my cousins whose
parents are my who's my family's polish
but you know they all married Iraqi men
for some reason in Israel and I I was
told don't discuss that you're working
on a pig farm you know among the
grandparents from Iraq and don't talk
about it it doesn't matter I was I don't
eat pork I've never eaten it I didn't
even eat pork while on the pig farm and
like just don't even mention it say you
wanted you know said that you're on a
goat farm you know and there was like a
fear because of this traditionalism
that's there but um I did I mean there's
the secular Israeli identity as I would
come to understand it and as it's been
articulated is very much in the Western
you know Western European tradition it's
you know and you see I feel like as more
conservative traditional Israelis you
know as they modernize and what you know
westernized you know as to become more
secular they're becoming more Western
you know and and so that I'm not sure if
I can articulate in that way but it's
that's what i would say i wouldn't say
it's an Ashkenazi Sephardic thing at all
although you I would say you would see a
higher percentage among of non-orthodox
safar diem of people keeping the pork a
prohibition I wanted to introduce the
theme all the association between pigs
and greed and like the catalyst peg and
generally kind of curious as to where
this association comes from but I wonder
whether there's also possibly a
religious dimension to this as well and
link to a kind of on one side the
pleasure of eating pork flesh and they
are gorging on pork and on the other
hand the kind of the elements are in a
lot of religions of asceticism and
self-denial and and refusing some of the
pleasures of the flesh and I just
wondered if anyone wanted to comment on
that Jill actually a lot of that comes
from from so the real popularity comes
from early Christian writers but also
some second nipple Jewish writers who
are trying to rationalize
philosophically these biblical taboos
but then particularly get this with
early Christian writers who are trying
to say that one should that the biblical
laws are metaphors and allegories
particularly so you should ignore you
can eat the animal but you can't act
like the animal so a pig is greedy of
all sorts of vultures and eagles they
snatch in the grab so you as long as
you're not thieving you can eat a pig um
or a lot of people will say oh the
biblical taboo against um about fish
right is they have to have fins and
scales and so it's against bottom
feeders but actually the first reference
that I could ever find to understanding
it as bottom feeders is a first century
ce e Christian text miss Leveaux animus
which is talks about how oh it's because
then those shellfish are down in the
muck and mire of the dirt and and you
can't be like that you have to elevate
yourself spiritually so you can eat the
oyster but you just can't act like it
you can eat is so and then I think that
um gets picked up on with other cultural
associations so that that's my um my
intuition and thank you all three of you
for those for those really great papers
night this is mostly to Jeff fragrance
but also to Jordan and I'm thinking
about in a contemporary period and think
about Islam and sort of a a perceived
other and particularly sort of a
dangerous hidden other also in the way
that the Jews have been considered
especially in Europe and I was thinking
about a news story this week or last
week
about a Palestinian man who had been
killed in his in territories I think and
where an Israeli settler had
intentionally defiled his body by
throwing pork at it and I think if
several years ago there was some attempt
at talking about pork bomb-sniffing pigs
similarly with a sort of this Israeli
idea of well Muslims really don't like
pigs so let's let's offend them in that
way so i was first I'll say one thing
that's interesting is these am in Israel
most of the pigs are being raised in the
north and the Christian Arab region but
those there's a lot of Christian Arab a
lot of Christian herbs are leaving and
they're going to different places or
they're leaving those regions and now
the majority Muslim and and you go into
some of these towns even Ilya all you
smell is the refuse of these of these
pigs from these you know these huge
industrial farms and it's a real it's
interesting real tension you know what's
going to be you know with you know it
does the Israeli pork industry rely on
on on the Muslim population you know in
Israel and what is what does that mean
and it's really confusing one of the
jokes in Israel I get not a good joke
I'm gonna 3m to this one is that there's
one of the teeth you know the you know
basically the only things that that
ultra or fundamentalist Jews and
fundamentalist Muslims agree on earth is
there you know kind of hatred of pigs in
their hatred of gays in Israel and this
comes up every time there's a stabbing
at the gay pride parades in Tel Aviv and
what's interesting is I found in this
the vilification of the pigs in Israel
I've just found a really a similarity
between the Muslim and the Jewish
perspective and it's not so much the
case in this in the States i found i
fell these more nuanced but I feel like
that's like um you know I you know you
have pig heads being thrown into into
mosques you know in Israel also in the
synagogue's you know and that's
something that's been happened you know
throughout history I mean so for me it's
I've been very interested in the
similarities I know there are
differences and I created a website
called pork memoirs which was alluded to
earlier
to collect stories from people about the
personal relationship to two pork and I
got a lot of a lot of responses from
from Jewish writers Jewish readers but I
didn't get many I didn't get many Muslim
stories I was trying to solicit them and
but there was this fear there was a way
that Muslims weren't comfortable talking
about maybe transgressing or talk openly
about you know exploring the
relationship to this creature this
animal any of that association I was
very interested in in that there was a
Jewish love talking about it even if
they didn't eat pig someone accidentally
got close to one and wrote a story you
know and so there's a different approach
but there is a similarity that I i seen
on the you know right-wing
fundamentalist perspective and to my
section both quickly I would just say
that and I sort of hinted at this how
its people focus on the Jewish aspect
but missed the Muslim aspect but I would
say that it's continuing a signification
being put into it it's still a rhetoric
of other pneus and how it's being used
and that's the fascinating thing is that
pig continues to be used as a way of
talking about self and other and you can
change some of the variables for things
but it's still functioning very
similarly to make an L sin of that
actually wanted to when I jumped on on
these last few questions and what
they're they're making me think about
it's striking to me how how the actual
wave figs are being raised and
reflection upon it has has not kind of
come into interpreting these various
identity issues I think it's quite
significant if the pig stands for the
despised other in these complicated ways
especially if you're saying things like
you know we have the Orthodox Jews total
hatred of pigs more nuanced in the u.s.
I mean think of this in terms of other
kind of political issues we might look
at it seems to be quite significant that
we're not just eating the pig we're
dominating the pig in this radical way
and though and the stories you told the
details it was such an honor if I mean
think about this the most famous pork
fire and Israel begins with a pig that
is made nothing that has made low clean
and I can't
I can't believe that these things are
simply accidental that is at some
unconscious level if I am making a point
of eating pork today as a point of
identity in a nation which raises park
in a particular way and there are
associations you know this is in part
you know I think tied into these very
troubling and dark things and when we
when we forget the pig I think we forget
these things you know so i think we
bring back in the pig of course the pig
is going to be very concerned with its
actual life and if we look at that life
and how its treated i think we'd see
some remarkable parallels to the
violence against humans and disregard
for humans there yeah and one quick
thing i would just say to that which is
I I what's interesting is hearing that
is so fast and thinking about the
experience of pigs in Israel they're all
there are no pasture raised pigs in the
country them at least not not legally
produced the Ministry of Agriculture
really is no oversight over a pork
production so some of these facilities
are some of the most mismanaged
facilities because it's it's a great
area in the law it's quasi-legal and no
one's checking up on it Thomas Friedman
wrote about when he covered this topic
in the new york times in the 80s he
called the Ministry of Agriculture to
ask about pigs and he likened it to like
as if he asked about cocaine that it was
impossible to get a single a response
and so ember these pigs are treated so
poorly i was on a farm that looked to EU
standards they look to the west to guide
them for how to morally raised in pigs
industrially and so yeah the pig as a as
a symbol has supplied to the pig as a
creature as an individual and i really i
really appreciate that especially yeah
we have two more people who mike sweeney
and then angie movie karate belt or a
very shortly i'm so glad this islam on
Arab Muslim majority perspective that
question was asked because it's very
obvious the gap is you know we needed
Islam specialist on the exam there isn't
one the absence of these long specials
I'm going to curse turn to Jordan sorry
Jordan doing that I was Theriot to
domino's a grad school because if I
remember go
are suspicious so can you please I
enlighten us about we have been talking
about the similarities from Jewish
perspective and stuffing perspective
towards pig differences and and and are
we talking about similar kind of
attitudes towards pork are we talking
about similar kind of impurity are we
talking about discussing or assuming
that our attitudes never differed
between these two religious traditions
or among communities who identified
themselves between these two religious
definitions religious identities that's
aspect of it um one thing that I noticed
in jerez presentation is this absence of
this one major actor which was mentioned
but not mentioned these ere Christians
this is pre-existing you know group of
people who are involved in this big
racing and how is that community how is
that actor this community of actors
involved in this state of Israel's
domestic pig industry just may briefly
so quickly for I think you're asking
about how variables different and
understanding pig identification and
attitude so what I would say is um the
pig it's not like the pig was consulted
of how do you feel about being
understood as a Jew how do you feel
about being understood as a Muslim and a
right so but that gets back to some of
the broader point that was bringing it
that actually I was trying to point I
agree um voice in Islam would be
wonderful because I was trying to point
towards how on it's it's funny how in
discussions of keg identification on
people and it ends with the Huckabee
thing right where he he could have said
a Jew and a Muslim how they would feel
about being forced to have like he
didn't have to go to another example he
had the same example could have worked
for both right on but there's a certain
rendering invisible pneus of that but
also part of that is on it sort of does
a disservice to both communities in that
sense right because it's rendering Islam
invisible one way but it's also forcing
an essential ISM of duty ISM in another
way and um what I'd say is that what you
see is some similarities and how it
retreated but on the pig is the
signification thing it can it can take
on whatever symbol whoever wants to
argue about it and sometimes it'll be
used to say a bad Jew is a pig a bad
chin is like a Jew who or like a pig a
bad Muslim is a pig or it so that it
gets put on with so much signification
that even within this quick history
lesson about Judaism there's there are a
lot of dissimilarities things and that's
what I was trying to show how the what's
being index is often inverted and so
what it says you can look for that um
and you would have to see how it's
continuously are being inverted based on
whatever's convenient for the accuser at
the time visa V the pic I'm sorry can
you take a second discussion and then to
thank you yeah this isn't a question
it's a very quick comment and an
amplification on the signal and the
signification of pigs and that is I
don't know if anybody else is here
here's from the interior south or from
the barbecue belt but but what you find
in the advertising of a barbecue joints
is the use I know yesterday Lori talked
about the restaurant of the universe and
that netcal that serve serves itself to
customers and what you find is something
slightly similar but slightly different
which is that you find pig butchers as
the sources of the BBQ that you're going
to eat in the in the BBQ Shack that
you're going to that you're going to eat
in so there's a wonderful in Lexington
Lexington I want to say it's called
sustain bees but anyway there's a lot
wonderful large life-size well larger
than life size human size statue of a
pig in a toke and a pitcher's cleaver
and you're gonna walk in an EPA and I
always interpret I've always seen this
as an infect an extension of being
kosher and not not so much as a
violation of a but rather evidence of
the fact that pork consumption is itself
transgressive that there's a way in
which what makes it possible to eat that
pig even for barbecue and Bible Belt
eating Christians is that is there is a
recognition of the other of the
transgressive character of that that is
that keep cannibalism is something that
is akin to it lends itself to the pig
and the pig exemplifies cannibalism in a
way that other you don't see this the
same kind of advertising with other
kinds of animals for example that you do
with pigs well I mean it's the inversion
of the the chick-fil-a thing right where
you have there the cow seeing is anymore
but also I add to that just quickly that
ancient rabbinic sources I mean Jewish
sources say all acknowledge that pig is
the most tastiest of all meats and in
fact they say it's important theological
e for you to acknowledge that because
then you are saying you are choosing
because God commanded it to not eat the
most tasty meat but of course in theory
they're having to claim that it's based
on other people's evidence on but even a
one left quick little zoo archaeological
thing is that I was sinister is that pig
bones everyone to talk about p bones and
jewish identity and say look there less
pig bones in this site so it must be
Jewish and they ignore the fact that
they're all these other non kosher bones
being slaughtered in the same place in
the same house but no one's to talk
about it because look oh it's less pig
bones they must be observant Jews as if
that's the that's the only symbol of it
and let's ignore all the other non
kosher animals at the reading so we have
been myself yeah I just wanted to go
back to the question of how identity is
marked and I have thought theoretically
if that if you wanted to invent a set of
rules that would prevent your people
from eating within other people you
couldn't do much better than Jewish
dietary rules historically right and so
the question is there are all kinds of
ways of marking identity some sects
historically in Southeast Asia by a
different set of clothes some by how
they may and so on that don't prevent
them from eating with other people and
so what is interesting I suppose is the
food prohibition that you because once
people are eating with one another
there's no telling what they might do
and so there the food prohibition seems
to me to have a particular effect as a
marker that other forms of
self-identification and boundaries do
not necessarily have and therefore it
seems to me to have something of a
different status in fact they the age of
abba's the my guys they knew it like
there's a this is text that actually a
scholar here Chris Hayes has worked on
omniverse book that um that we're
basically the rabbi's say on what if
you're invited to a idolaters wedding
feast
can you go to it and they said no and
this is what what if I bring my own food
so it's kosher and I bring my own
servants and I so everything so it's not
about the food and they said no not not
allowed and the idea being that that
whole event is is not kosher right but
they're clearly saying okay you're
saying no because it's the food or
there's another text where they say what
okay wine is not allowed because of non
idolatrous wine because they're going to
pour out a little libation so what about
beer or any other non wanna toxin which
is not used in a libation forms and so
um the rabbi said well you can't and the
answer is masoom cuts in it which means
because of intermarriage and then they
say there are two rabbis one more strict
than the other so one would go to a
Gentile bar order his beer stand outside
the bar get them to bring it out and
then drink it then the other one was a
little more strict so he would wait till
he got home and crossed his the
threshold his house then he drink it so
that text so unambiguously says it's
about the social in fact the food itself
is kosher it's sitting down next to him
saying oh hey you're really gonna do
maybe maybe your sister you know let's
chat about this and it's saying that you
can't on you can't go to a bar and it's
all about the social situation so
they're they're clearly acknowledging
that that so it's not even just you
reading into it they saved for the
because we had a forward actually for us
has just arrived we're still setting
things up so if there are any really a
comment section yeah I just wanted to
make a quick on the gentleman actually
still has the mic who is bringing up in
the context of the South these
interesting images of you know pigs
participating in their own slaughter I
mean I think we need there's a whole
literature and african-americans and
pigs and the incident which came up in
jordans I mean it's a literature I'm not
yet familiar with but I certainly know
part of what it's bound up with is the
way the domination of pigs in the
domination of blacks comes together and
I think we really and these questions of
identification are so important and I
think they are what scholars can bring
to the table of ultimately the pragmatic
decisions that share our but we do have
a ten
see to forget these macro frames in
which things are occurring in and I just
want to call our attention for that
again yeah i just wanted to respond to
the christian arab question i don't want
to do you mean to leave it hanging so
just one what's interesting is that I
guess that you know there was really a
tradition of raising pigs in the north
of Israel among these Christian Arab
communities and I feel like one of the
the effects of this law and then the
partnerships that developed between the
secular Israeli keep would seem bringing
their pigs this region and with these
christian arabs is that that way of
agriculture seem to have you know really
no longer exists it's all become
industrialized because of the
concentration of the industry so what's
sad is that I you really can't go and
find these old traditional agricultural
methods it's also really hard to visit
this region because the entire industry
is veiled in secrecy it takes you know
different networks of connect
connections to finally find someone and
I was supposed to you know I was going
to the region I was meeting with the
farmer I was 10 minutes late to this
meeting point and then he would never
call me back again you know and people
really scared and nervous and and the
Christian music Christian have regions
have really been sort of like a lot of
the communities in North Carolina that
are near some of the you know the big
you know k foes they've really I mean
these areas are incredibly polluted and
it's really a big problem that no one's
really talking about because it's just
not something that's really talked about
openly and I would just say that the
whole industry itself is is is is even
though now it's more illegal than it was
but it's still not entirely legal if
these exemptions to get on to that pig
farm with slav I had to I wasn't allowed
they wouldn't let me on ever worried I
was religious when I tried calling just
to visit for a day or two the only way I
could get on to the farm was to sign up
as a kibbutz to volunteer and I then had
to get a letter from my rabbi in New
Jersey a certificate of my bar mitzvah
to then prove that I could become a
volunteer at the kibbutz programs office
to then go to then go on work on this
pig farm you know for free as a
keyboards volunteer to do my
research so I because no one would let
me in so that so not much is known about
the christian era pig farmers there
hasn't been that much written and and
from my discussions with a few I
Christian Arab fig members it's that
it's not something that they really want
to put out there i will say there is an
interesting tradition of christian arabs
of the north hunting war and there are
it's illegal to serve hunted boar in any
restaurant although there are a lot of
subversive chefs in Tel Aviv who have
big boar roasts on Yom Kippur and you
know the chef of your heart ye love haha
means our and he has his uh he you know
he's his hunter in the North who brings
him whenever he's got a catch he you
know what so that's kind of a little uh
I wish I had a better answer it's just
it's really hard to know because of that
those layers of secrecy okay maybe this
final question before we break for lunch
it's more more comment than a question
but it's interesting from a paleo
genomic perspective that when pigs first
arrived in the Levant they are clearly
Near Eastern origin as Ben was
discussing their from Anatolian they're
coming further down and then in the Iron
Age there's a massive migration of
European pigs that come into the lavon's
before then domestic pigs start to
disappear from that region but when you
look at the wild boar from the region
they are all effectively feral pigs from
prior from domestic pigs that were from
Europe so they have a really interesting
genetic mixture between an ultimate Near
Eastern origin but mixed with a
significant European one and they
colleague who is of mine in Israel who
is doing this work was really struggling
to even discuss this because even though
we're talking about two three four or
five thousand years ago the whole idea
that there were ever domestic pigs in
the Levant prior like thousands of years
prior to the origin of Israel as a
religion was somehow and you can't talk
about things at all and so she was
struggling to get research money to
investigate this even though the nature
of the wild boar in the region is
fascinating and would point a great deal
toward understanding the whole history
of human migration in the area and the
relationship between humans and animals
in
in the ridge writ large so it's just
kind of an interesting thing that she
couldn't even tell people what she was
doing even though it's thousands of
years prior to all right thank you um
like to take if I don't go in for a very
lively discussion